Salvador illa would win the elections
Amazonas and Puigdemont
would surpass Esquerra.
The first survey for next year's elections
12 de Mayo reveals 1 Clara Victoria of PSG.
According to the results,
the candidate of the Socialist Party of Catalonia,
Salvador illa,
would win 42 seats,
although it would remain
at a certain distance from the absolute majority,
which is set at 86 seats.
According to public reports,
the Spanish
yuns would be the second most voted option.
with 1 total of 33 seats,
Esquerra would remain with 28 seats.
In this scenario,
Salvador illa
would be found
the need to seek the support of Esquerra and yuns
to be invested as New
Chairman of the Generalitat.
I could not achieve victory with the support of the comune.
nor adding the PP,
since it would also need the support of Vox.
However,
the task of ensuring governance
by the independence movement would be very complicated.
Yungi Esquerra would not add up
nor would they do so with the support of cu.
This would mean 1 change
radical in Catalonia and in general.
For the first time since 2012
independence
would lose its absolute majority in Parliament